disney is also doubling down on this
disney we've been covering this a lot
over the last couple weeks all of this
leaked video has come out that tons of
their activist employees
who mostly should probably be in mental
institutions they are telling you they
are hiding this stuff in their
programming they are intentionally going
out of their way to push this woke
ideology uh and now
the disney ceo his name's bob chappic
and i didn't know much about bob chappic
before this whole fight that he got into
with ron desantis but i suspect
i suspect that bob chapic got the job as
disney ceo because he was a pretty
competent executive disney is one of the
most powerful
corporations in the world
culturally it might be the most powerful
corporation in the world it owns all of
our dreams at this point right it owns
all of the stories it owns star wars it
owns mickey mouse it owns marvel that's
a huge problem that a giant corporation
would have that much influence over the
stories that become the lore of our
world i think it's one of the reasons
that we're so broken right now that we
don't have good stories anymore because
this because giant corporations whether
they're woke or not can't churn out good
true original stories disney is the evil
villain of a disney story in any way in
any case disney ceo bob chappie uh he
got into the fight with desantis uh he
said you know they basically summon
desantis as if he's the king and
desantis did not take any of his [ __ ]
and said no i don't care i don't care
that you have 70 000 employees here in
orlando uh i am i am the chief executive
for the people that elected me and the
and and for the people who didn't elect
me for all the citizens of florida
actually and we don't want this woke
crap in our schools and by the way a lot
of parents who take their kids to
disneyland and watch your stupid movies
don't want it either well
despite desantis trying to smack some
sense into this clown bob chappic uh
here he is groveling
pathetically
groveling at the altar of his activist
employees i pledged to be a better ally
for the lgbtq plus community
apologize for not being the ally that
you needed me to be and committed to
ensuring that our company lives up to
its values
i meant every word
and that's what we're here to talk about
today i understand that we've made
mistakes and the pain that those
mistakes have caused and i know that our
silence wasn't just about the bill in
florida but about every time an
individual or institution that should
have stood up for this community did not
i and the leadership team are determined
to use this moment as a catalyst for
more meaningful and lasting change i
want to thank the
lgbtqia plus advisory council their
allies and everyone else who has
submitted ideas on how we can take
action
that seems authentic doesn't that seem
authentic i feel like they've got
they've got mickey like standing right
behind him like
with a gun they've got like bisexual
mickey or something
these people are just horrible they're
broken woke morons and cowards that's
what they all people want to know what's
the grand conspiracy like who's pushing
this why are they all pushing it i don't
know what it's all about but i know it's
a it's a mix of of a lot of stuff right
it's a mix of woke activists and
algorithms and and crazy people who
don't know what reality is anymore and
then it's pathetic spineless people like
the disney ceo